they see you in the distance they sense
your breath and they feel the heat of
your skin but despite their tiny brains
mosquitoes probably smell you first from
far away
this is a special facility for simulated
blood sucking a 1 000 cubic meter box in
the Zambian Forest enclosed by Nets with
six pods for real humans to sleep in we
like to think of it as the world's
largest perfumery for mosquitoes each
tent is connected to a heated Landing
Pad fitted with infrared cameras that
watch as hungry mosquitoes look for a
nightly feed
the researchers who built it are trying
to understand how the bugs pick their
victims and this is quite um similar to
what a mosquito would experience in
nature um when the African malaria
mosquito actually enters a home
um it actually has to follow
um warmth currents emitted from the
human body of sleeping humans and often
humans are housed in groups it's a quite
a busy smelling task for the mosquitoes
malaria a parasite that is carried by
mosquitoes kills more than half a
million people every year and nearly
half of the world is exposed to it it's
quite surprising that mosquitoes also
have are quite a complex nervous system
their brain actually looks uh
orthologous or similar to our brain uh
believe it or not a very very uh tiny
insect with a powerful sense of smell
under the camera one of the landing pads
it's warm and it emits carbon dioxide
just like us but there are no human
sense so no mosquitoes another same
conditions but with some characteristic
human smells
a third and now the smells are different
the researchers are assembling a menu to
isolate the most irresistible whiffs we
are absolutely
developing a synthetic compounds for
example you can actually poison them for
example so that they they are lowered to
a specific trap and then poison them so
that you reduce the biting of of these
vectors on on humans although the battle
against malaria is waged across many
fronts this could help us understand why
and how malaria carrying mosquitoes find
us in the night the more you understand
the enemy the better equipped you are in
fighting the enemy so it feels very very
I don't know what way to use but it's
very exciting Colin Baker Al Jazeera
still ahead's on the Al Jazeera NewsHour